Currently this is our forecast list.
It looks okay, but it would be nice
if we could show the degree symbol
for these temperature values.
Using this notation is best practice.
It will help the translator
know how to reorder the text
and the parameters
so that it fits the local language.
Now let's look at how
we can use this method
to format temperatures within our app.
Within the string.xml file, we declared
the format temperature string resource.
We use XLIFF tags to denote
that this is where
the decimal temperature value will go.
This is followed by the unit code
character for the degrees symbol.
In the utility class, in the format
temperature method,
we can use this string resource.
Remember that in this method,
we take in a temperature
and a user's preference
for metric or imperial.
Then we return the
converted temperature.
We're going to modify this method
so that it also returns
the formatted string with a degrees
symbol after the value.
In order to do this, we need
to pass in a context,
From the context we can get access
to the string resource ID
that we declared earlier.
Then we passed in any additional
parameters for that string template.
In this case we only have one parameter
so we pass in the temperature value.
Then this fully formatted string
gets returned to the caller.
This method is used in the forecast list,
as well in the detail page.
So we also have to update
the code there
so that it would compile
with this new parameter.
And this is what the app looks like
after the change.
Go ahead and make the change in your code
to add a string resource
for displaying temperature in degrees.
Check this box when you're done.
And remember, use this notation
going forward, for when
you need to format strings.